can you tell us why the movie ordinary
people
was a defining moment in your life
i think when i saw ordinary people
i was about 17 years old and it was the
first
really serious
movie i had seen you know after
[Music]
it also really spoke to who i was as a
kid i was
a
kind of a socially awkward
lonely kid and so i felt you know
whatever discomfort went with
with that and
ordinary people showed this main
character
who looked on the outside
like he had everything together and
like he didn't
experience the kind of pain
that i experienced
but then the film because it's
a beautifully told story
reveals
his secret life
and in his secret life he's actually
just come out of
treatment
after a suicide attempt and he's going
to high school he's singing in the choir
he looks to everyone like
he's
one of the ones who's really got it all
together
and for the first time as i sat in the
audience i realized
oh it's possible
that what's on the surface isn't what's
really going on
um underneath
that's i guess something adults know i
didn't know that as a 17 year old and
so that film
showed me that i wasn't the only one
so that was that was the first thing
that made a huge difference uh to me and
then the second thing was i realized
oh so the people around me might
actually be in pain
even though it's not obvious i need to
treat people differently
and that is something that has
continued to shape me
you know decades later i look at people
differently because of what that film
taught me about
other human beings
and then the third thing for me
was
i saw for the first time what a movie
could be and so i thought
this is what i want to do i want to tell
these kinds of stories that reveal
characters and that
move people that provide meaningful
emotion
so for me seeing ordinary people became
a dividing line in my own life on
multiple levels and so for me that is a
defining moment
and i assume you saw it in the theater i
did i saw it in the theater
i owned the dvd it still wrapped in
cellophane because i can't bear to go
back and watch it i'm afraid it either
is not as good as i remember or
it will be
[Music]
i don't know i i don't want it to
disappoint me and so i just keep it
under wraps
yeah yeah i can agree with doing so it's
almost like it's frozen in time there's
something special there that's exactly
right yeah and i don't want to disturb
that memory
because that memory is vivid and
is kind of a bedrock of
the person i've become
and how were other people leaving the
theater after watching that film
i think other people were
powerfully moved by it mary tyler moore
delivers a fantastic performance as the
sort of
cold-hearted
mother who is
the whole time she's on screen you fear
she's driving her son to suicide and i
remember wanting to like take my shoe
off in the theater and show it at this
throw it at the screen when she was on
screen which is you know what a
testament to
to that performance
so i think you know other people were
really moved i'm not sure how many
people
uh would
point back to that experience as a
defining moment in their lives it's one
of the things about film i think that
is
fascinating to me that we all have
different responses to it that are
partly shaped by the film itself but
partly shaped by us and uh what we bring
to the film
who are the characters and ordinary
people so you've got the dad uh played
by donald sutherland uh the mom played
by mary tyler moore and then the 17 year
old son
and then there's a there's another
brother who's really absent from the
movie because he
drowned um
before the events of the movie
that was a defining moment for that
family and each one of these
characters responds in a different way
mary tyler moore's mother character
kind of makes it clear to her surviving
son that she wishes
that the other brother had survived and
that becomes
the
seed of
his misery
is that sense of being
rejected
by his mother and his dad is
trying to figure out how to put his
family back together after the tragic
loss of the one son
and the just the terrible chemistry
that's going on between mother and the
surviving son played by timothy hutton
and
they're all doing the best they can
but it it
it feels so
real uh at least to me sitting in the
theater it felt like this is a real
family i didn't feel like i was watching
a movie and
uh and i think that that's also
informed
even
the way that i approach writing uh
as a screenwriter that's the tone i go
for i love
naturalism
i don't write big bombastic
comic book kinds of material because
that's not what speaks to me
it is that sense of i've gotten lost in
a dream
and
this feels
in some ways more real than reality
because
a great film
reveals more of the characters
than
sometimes i'm able to discover of the
people that i actually know
and i find i really crave
understanding who's really there and so
a film that shows that to me i really
love and i
i strive to
do that as a storyteller as well to
really peel back the layers and reveal
who the characters are that we're
dealing with
i'm just curious when did you purchase
the dvd to ordinary people
um
i probably bought that something like 10
years ago you know i think i just came
across it
on a shelf somewhere
and um
when i first
had that thing in my hands i thought
well i should i should watch this and
that i just kind of felt resistance uh
in myself to that and so then it ended
up on my shelf of dvds and now it's
even hard to find a dvd player in the
house if i wanted to watch it
can you give us a general explanation of
what a defining moment is
kathy
who's my co-author and my wife and i
first encountered the idea of defining
moments
through
a
mentor of ours a
television writer producer named coleman
lock
and he was mentoring us through a
rewrite of a feature film
that we
we had written early in our careers
called after the truth
and
um coleman made us work uh really really
hard he told us we would come to hate
him
and i thought that that was hyperbole
but he was right he pushed us so hard
we didn't come to hate him we have a
tremendous respect for him
but i remember foolishly asking him at
one point do other writers really work
this hard
and
i've come to find out yes they do the
good ones do
but he he had this idea that he shared
with us and the idea was
all of us
have a handful of experiences that have
profoundly shaped us
so we live through lots of moments every
day in our lives but not every moment is
equal in terms of its impact on shaping
us
and coleman believed that there were
about maybe a half dozen
moments that each one of us could point
to
that
account for much of the person that we
are today and his idea was that
the same would be true of characters and
if we wanted to deeply understand our
characters what drives them
um
how that broken character got broken
or how that broken character eventually
heals
that we would
locate that half dozen or so
moments that have defined those
characters
and that that would actually be more
valuable than understanding how much
change is in the character's pocket or
you know so many of the infinite number
of details that we could
know about about a character
coleman's thought was
it is these moments that define the
character that
tell you more than anything else you
could possibly know
and
so kathy and i began doing that work
with our characters
looking into their pasts to discover the
moments that it shaped them
and then looking into
the time of the story the time that's
actually unfolding in a movie or
television
episode and saying what are the
the moments that happened live in front
of our eyes that
not only
have formed a character but now
in
in real time before us transform
the character into who they're becoming
so
um
for us what we discovered uh about
defining moments that helps us to locate
them is they always tend to create this
boundary between before and after
we talk about the time
before the house burned down and the
time after the house burned down
all of us
on this planet will talk about the time
before the pandemic
and
please god the time after the pandemic
at some point
so the planet can have a defining moment
individually we can have defining
moments families can have defining
moments and certainly characters
if they are lifelike
we'll have moments that define them as
well
how many defining moments are there in
ordinary people
boy you know in ordinary people because
it's been so many decades since i saw
the film that i can just say off the top
of my head
there was the moment of the drowning
so when
the oldest brother
dies tragically
that is a moment that defines the whole
family
and then also and so that happens before
the movie begins and then another
defining event is
when timothy hutton's
attempts suicide
and that creates another
before and after moment
for purposes of the film
the impact of that attempted suicide is
that
we as the audience as soon as we know
about that
are on the edge of our seats because we
fear
that
he's going to
complete the act
that he's going to take his life
and
we like this kid
and we view that
that would be tragic and so we are
rooting for that not to happen
we are
infuriated by his mother's coldness
to him
every time he tries to connect with her
she
pushes him away
and
we just want to scream at her don't you
see
what's happening don't you see how much
he needs you can't you
put your arms around your son
all of that
is rooted in that defining moment of the
suicide attempt which is
made known to the audience so that we we
get the good out of it we get the
emotional juice that flows from that
and
then
there's a defining moment of
a kind of connection if i am remembering
the movie correctly that happens between
timothy timothy hutton and his dad
donald sutherland
that
makes you believe that maybe they're
going to make it
and so it creates this other turning
point a kind of
a kind of
provisional healing
there may be more in there those are the
three that
that remain in my memory
so it's a film of
a lot of pain and
grief
but it's also a hopeful film
but it's bittersweet because
the mom's character doesn't
get to participate in that
reconciliation and again if i go back
and never crack open that dvd i may find
out i'm remembering wrong but in my
memory those are the three key defining
moments that
uh
immediately come to my mind
can you explain why a writer must
understand their own story before they
can essentially understand any character
stories that they may invent
my wife cassie took this idea of
defining moments and
pushed it a step further by saying this
isn't just about
concocting
moments for our characters it really
begins with us
understanding our own story so she
when she teaches young writers we'll say
again and again before you can
understand
your character story you have to
understand your own story
so if we're going to understand the
dynamic of the way moments can reshape
us and transform us
the best place for us to look is in our
own experience
we have a front row seat to our own
invisible inner emotional life and so
we've got to
be willing to uh to draw on that
but before i can draw on my own
life my own defining moments i have to
actually
locate them
so
while i might not want to crack open
an old dvd
i have to crack open my own history if
i'm going to tap into
the emotional
riches
that lie there for
all of us because we all
have
uh in the words of author frederick
beekner wonderful and terrible things
that have happened to us all
and so
the idea is that we would look at those
things
so as an example
a kind of moment that might define us
would be
the moment a dream was born
and so somebody who's pursuing acting
directing writing
often
that
that's based around a dream
and so the question that i would ask is
when was that dream born
can you locate
the moment of
birth for that dream
and sometimes there is a moment
and sometimes things
emerge
so gradually
that we can't locate a moment we've got
glaciers that creep imperceptibly but
then we also have glaciers when they
reach the sea
that in
dramatic fashion will cave a glacier in
a moment
what we're interested in as dramatists
are those dramatic moments
so the tectonic plates of the earth
move
meter by millimeter over the decades
centuries millennia
it's not that interesting to watch
but there is an instant when they
rupture
and we have an earthquake those are the
dramatic moments
so there are times when
changes happen in us
by these gradual processes
and
that we may not call those defining
moments but there are these cataclysmic
seismic moments of change
that
make great stories but also really help
to define
that change happened
so you might look back and say let me
locate
what is that moment where i became
obsessed with screenwriting
when is that moment when i had to make
movies or had to make television
we also think about
characters and we think about people as
being
broken damaged
and
so we can look back and say not only
um
i know i've limped like this for a long
time but we can ask the question when
did i get that limp
what was the moment of injury
and if we understand that moment we get
a great story but we also understand
maybe
if this is how it happened with me
this may be how it happens with my
characters as well
and
i don't only want to tell bleak stories
about people being injured and damaged i
i am interested in a credible kind of
hope and so i'm also interested in
asking
like was there ever a time where i grew
was there ever a time where i healed
that i overcame a fear
what did that moment look like
and if i understand that in myself
then i'm in a position
to
portray that in a character
and
that will be lifelike and emotionally
authentic because it's rooted in
something that i've actually
experienced so i think that that is the
vulnerability and the cost that comes
with being a storyteller
is that we have to be willing to
do that dive into
our our own emotional story
and be willing
disguised or not to to bring those
stories forward
and it's tough
you go into a
meeting at a studio and you sit with a
producer or an executive and you pitch
this character arc and you say i think
this is where this character's damage
comes from and what you're really
telling is a story from your own history
you don't necessarily tell them that
but if that gets shot down
well that's a little bit vulnerable uh
that's sort of a rejection of you and
your pain and and your past
but
there's also the possibility that the
producer will say oh that's right
something like that happened to me
and suddenly you've got a common
point of reference for this character
certainly when you are
communicating with a big audience if
those moments actually make it to the
screen
you've created the possibility of
connection with
thousands of people millions of people
in a way that they really relate to
and
when we connect at that deep level with
characters
we care
we're invested emotionally in what
happens to them that's what gets us
sitting on the edge of our seats
it's not just that we've got
spectacular visual effects and
characters zipping across the screen if
i don't care about those characters
i'm bored
with even the most spectacular visual
effects
if i identify with a character and
deeply care what happens to them
then the tiniest
movement either toward or away from
danger
i i feel viscerally uh so i think that's
the value for writers
in connecting with their own defining
moments so that they can then
enrich their work with
the insights they gain
some of our comments i've seen people
mention that they didn't
have anything too tragic to write about
but they were still able to
portray that in their stories and they
said you know i didn't come from a
dysfunctional family and i had a great
childhood but
there's this myth that i have to be
damaged in order to be a great writer do
you ever see people that are just
too far on the spectrum either
everything is just tragic and woe was me
and there was no growth and then others
that
now everything was like disneyland
i do encounter writers a lot who when i
ask them
to find moments that have shaped them
struggle with that and often discount
their life experience as boring or low
stakes
and i had
i had one student who was not
a 20 year old uh
who came to me i knew that she was a
pediatrician
and
but she came to me with this
problem of nothing's happened to me
and i said well
so your career is you work in the
hospital with
desperately ill children and their
families
i think you have experienced
deeply emotional high-stakes
things
and she thought about it and she said
well
i guess it's true i am a 50-year-old
woman and no man has ever loved me
and i said
then you
you have lots of stories you have
deep emotion
but
i think we have to honor
our own life experience and not
dismiss it as unimportant
now somebody who only like who wallows
in tragedy and damage
i think that we
i think that we want more than stories
of chaos
i think we do want stories that help us
make sense of
lives that often feel like chaos to us
at least
while we're in the middle
of
the story
and so
i really value stories told by writers
who are able to
to go out into life and experience it
and come back and help make some sense
of it even if it is
not the neat disney package
[Music]
i think of
joel and ethan cohen's no country for
old men
and
there's not a ton of hope in that movie
there's a line of uh i think it's
tommy lee jones who says you can't stop
what's coming referring to
just the sort of growing evil that he
was seeing in the world as a
sheriff or marshall in texas
that's kind of hopeless you can't stop
what's coming
toward the end of the film
tommy lee jones character tells a story
of riding out
into the wilderness i think it's a dream
he has
he's on a horse riding out into the
wilderness and his dad has ridden out
ahead of him
and has lit a campfire
and he says in his dream he's riding
along and he catches sight
far off in the distance of that campfire
and that's it
that's all the hope that there is in
that movie
but it's enough
to say
somewhere out there in the darkness
uh there is warmth and there is light
keep writing
that can be
for somebody who
experiences
a lot of adversity
that can ring true to them in a way that
a disney movie
never will
that can be credible hope and so
i value that kind of storytelling and i
would push a
a writer who
only sees bleakness
uh to look harder in the same way that i
would encourage
a writer who only sees
happiness
to be more honest with themselves and
own up to
whatever the pain and disappointments
have been that's hard to do
i think sometimes that can only happen
after some therapy and after some years
have passed and we can dare
to
crack open the package and look inside
i think the audience craves that kind of
that kind of honesty
you're trying to remember back to patch
adams it's been a little bit since i've
seen it but speaking of a pediatrician
i think at some point it's revealed why
the character wants to
you know bring joy to these children and
sort of this clown-esque type
yeah i think there's some
tragic past which keeps it from
being
a silly movie it's not a silly movie
and
it is
it's the pain and the darkness that
balances out
the
the fact that he wears a clown nose
to clinic
he he knows something about pain and of
course
robin williams
knew a lot about pain was well
acquainted with that and
that undergirded
both his dramatic acting and his comic
acting
how does a writer find defining moments
in their own life
kathy and i have developed a kind of a
list of characteristics that we think
describe defining moments and that they
help us
when we go looking for defining moments
so that list includes things like the
moment a dream was born it could be the
moment a dream died
uh sometimes defining moments are
moments of birth or death
and that can be a
literal death
or it could be a figurative death the
death of a business
the death of a relationship
or the birth of a relationship
we think about
moments of discovery
so
for a child who's been adopted the
moment they discover that they were
adopted might
redefine their understanding of
themselves
a special kind of discovery is a lesson
that's learned
so dorothy in oz
makes the discovery that there's no
place like home
and that discovery becomes the mantra
that allows her to travel back to kansas
it was the discovery that she needed
when she set out from kansas
she didn't think
that the people at home were special
enough to cherish
she thought that real life
lay somewhere out there and
along the way she makes the discovery
that there's no place like home and that
redefines who she is
sometimes we're looking for a moment
when
uh
a wound
was suffered
or a loss was incurred
other times
we're looking for a moment of
the birth of hope or
a moment of healing a moment of
deep
emotional
or spiritual change
and
with that
it's not a checklist but that
those categories
we can look at our own lives
and say well
um
what was a moment of deep emotional
change
that i've experienced if i'm a morose
person
um
was i always that way
and if not when did that change
kathy
uh
[Music]
found a
an old black and white picture of her
dad
when he was a young boy
and kathy's dad
as i knew him was a serious
mechanical engineer
and
not not playful that's the last word i
would use for him and yet this picture
showed this impish kid with this like
wicked smile on his face
and
kathy and her brother turned to each
other when they found this picture and
said did you know that person
and they both said
no i never met that guy
well
what was the moment
when he went from the playful imp
to
the
very serious
very dour
person that
my wife grew up with
that
at least turns our gaze in the right
direction and we can start looking and
see seeing is there
is there a moment like that
now there are times i think that
uh we can't find the moment
either because it happened
when we were so young that we have no
memory of it or it may be so traumatic
that
we have not allowed ourselves to
remember it
uh but we know we walk with the limp
and i discovered in myself
a
sort of evidence of a wound
that i don't ever remember suffering
but i remember as far back as six years
old
having
having the damage
and so i don't know what that defining
moment was i just know that it exists
and i know that i learned from that
experience that i must not
let people
know the real me or they would not want
me
uh i learned that men are dangerous
and
i had to
um
i have no memory
that accounts for those things but i had
to
look at that
history nonetheless and recognize those
lies as being so deep in my
in my firmware
that
i couldn't remember a time where they
weren't there and then i had to
i had to learn
the truth
that would neutralize those lies
and
i still feel like those lies are true
but i now know they're not and i'm able
to tell myself
here's the truth
there are people who actually know you
and they actually love you
and so the lie that if people know you
they won't love you that's a lie no
matter how
how that feels
and i've learned i'm not a little little
boy anymore and i don't have to be
afraid of grown-ups
it's not actually dangerous to have
human encounters even though it still
feels dangerous to me
well so i've just described a moment of
healing
that's also a defining moment
i had to be more than 50 years old
to experience that moment of healing
this to me is the advantage
that writers have with every passing
year
we keep getting more and more life
experience and so we have more and more
to draw on
if you're 20
well you've been through middle school
so you have you know you've come through
at least one war that's painful yes and
so
um you know i always think of the
popular kids i i i'm not sure they exist
i i i haven't met anyone as an adult who
says oh yeah i breezed through eighth
grade it was awesome my favorite year
it's it's just awful
but
a 20 year old is going to have 20 years
of life experience
a 40 or a 50 or a 60 year old writer is
going to have
more life experience and so
while
the industry may have a preference you
know for 22 year old writers because
it's exciting like it's exciting to get
a new sports car
mostly we give awards out to people with
a little more mileage on them
and it's because in part
of
the greater life experience which gives
you more access to
these kinds of moments
you know you just jog my memory because
i knew someone who was
considered very popular and they worried
their worry was they thought hey
everyone thought they were stuck up
and b they were worried about their
image and when they left the house how
did they look to everybody so to them
that was a huge concern because they
were afraid of breaking that image
and to me i saw the person as had it all
together and
they had all these people around them
that wanted to be around them but they
were terribly concerned so i guess
you're right that to them it was still
tragic i i i do think about um
[Music]
people whose faces are on magazine
covers and um
there is a burden
that goes with that now we might think
oh you know hoo you're you're beautiful
and famous
but
um
there is a
there's a burden that goes even with
the popularity that that rises to the
level of celebrity
uh of
an acquaintance once said to one of my
children
you don't know how hard it is to be so
pretty
and at the time i thought
that's a line i need to put in a script
but you know as you as you
talk i think no that actually
for
for this young lady
she experienced that as
as pain and anxiety and
um all of
all of that kind of human experience is
interesting to me both as a human but
also as a storyteller that's an
interesting character uh it's not that
wasn't my life experience but um
it's it's an experience that's
interesting to me
is there a limit on how many defining
moments someone can have in their life
you know i've been thinking a lot lately
about defining moments
and uh
i keep discovering more of them
for myself
uh
i'm not sure that the half dozen is any
sort of absolute limit at all i
you know i think that
our lives
don't continue in a straight line
uh there are reversals
uh there are moments of transformation
our lives
seem to unfold kind of in chapters
we don't just do the same thing the same
way forever
well the whole world with
covid has experienced that that
things actually change
sometimes quite dramatically
so
i could probably put my finger on a
dozen
[Music]
moments that
from my own life that are pretty
profound
and create
distinct moments of before and after
so i don't know that there's an absolute
limit
i just think that practically speaking
when we come to
characters
we probably want
to work with a manageable number of them
so we don't dilute
their
impact and their power
uh
especially if we're thinking of a
standalone feature film if we're talking
about a television series that goes for
many many episodes
then
you probably could
do justice to a dozen defining moments
over
you know 100 episodes if anybody
is doing 100 episodes anymore
at some point it um
you know
aristotle talked about
how many acts there should be in any
any play
and he said well it just depends how
long the play is
because an act
has to do with a reversal
and
there he says there should be a big
reversal
in each act
a life that is nothing but reversal
starts to feel
not like a real life
it would be like a football game where
there was an interception or a fumble on
every play it just becomes absurd
but
he says you've got to have enough of
them
to keep it interesting
so that's his formula he doesn't tell us
you know how many acts there should be
in a one-hour television pilot
but the general principle is there
should be enough to keep it interesting
but not so many
that it becomes absurd and i suppose the
same could be said of defining moments
once a writer has processed their own
defining moments how do they begin to
apply that knowledge to the characters
that they create well when i think about
applying
the idea of defining moments to
characters
uh i think in terms of these categories
so
if i've got a character who
has a dream
i've already looked back at
my moment of watching ordinary people
and seeing this dream of somehow getting
my fingers into the clay of filmmaking
so i know about how at least one dream
was born
then i can come to my character and say
for this character what does it look
like when their dream was born now their
dream may be to be an astronaut
and so i would think about well
what is
analogous
from my experience to their experience i
was watching a movie
an astronaut dream might have been born
as somebody was watching
a shuttle launch
or
the tragic loss of a shuttle
that immediately interests my writer's
brain because it's unexpected that you
would
see a catastrophic loss of a space
shuttle and say
that's what i want to do
but
i think that's actually often how it
works
i've described television writing
to
aspiring writers and the atmosphere in
the writer's room and how you have to
compete to get
your joke on the page and
how cutthroat that can be
and i think i've just talked to everyone
out of wanting to be a television writer
and then people will crowd to the front
and say that sounds fantastic that's
exactly what i want to do so that tells
me
that sometimes it's even
seeing
[Music]
a story that seems like it would drive
you away
that actually attracts the die-hard
dreamer
so i i bring that sort of general
experience from life i kind of mix it up
with
what i've observed in myself
and i i will often try to brainstorm
a bunch of different options
uh of what that defining moment might be
until i find one that both
feels
emotionally real
and also it makes an interesting story
because i might
have the character tell the story or we
may flash back to see that story
uh the writer bill marcilli uh who wrote
the film deja vu
talks about
his discipline of brainstorming 20
options
for
any creative choice
and his theory he says is that no one is
smart enough to come up with 20 bad
ideas in a row
so
one of your 20 ideas is bound to be
decent
so i've taken the calling that
marcelli's rule of 20.
it is a discipline
because often when we're coming up with
say a potential defining moment for a
character we want to
just
jump at the first thing that occurs to
us
part of
becoming a mature writer is recognizing
that it's not supposed to be that easy
and so we want to stick with it and keep
coming up with options so that we don't
pick the first thing that occurs to us
which probably is the first thing that
is going to occur to everyone else
we want to get to
something else further down the line
that's unexpected that we haven't seen
before
and if i'm drawing from my own
life experiences
that has a real chance of being fresh
because it's drawn from life
not from the movies
so that would be how i would go about
finding say one defining moment so a
dream is born
maybe in the course of the film this
dream is going to die
so then i would look at my own life and
also
lives of people around me that i know
well and say where have i seen
a dream die
and i can think for myself a defining
moment
[Music]
where
dreams died
and
in my experience dreams die slowly
they die kicking and screaming we don't
want to admit
that thing that you dreamed is not going
to happen
and so i would draw on that and
say how do i how do i bring that
to this character
and i would keep doing that until i had
that handful of moments that
gives me an understanding
of this character that makes them
complex
and relatable
and interesting
and when i really i can feel myself
when a character starts to come alive in
this way
and i i know i want to spend time with
that character and i want to hear
the dialogue that they're going to say
and i want to see them get into
whatever trouble the story is getting
them into and i want to see them
struggle
to get out of that trouble to get to
their goal
and i also want to watch them
grow over the course of that story
either
for good or for ill they're going to
change
and they're going to change
in in these moments these pivot points
and so i just keep at it um
until
i feel like
i have
this full character it's it's an organic
messy
uh
process definitely not paint by the
numbers but
having
my own
history and an understanding of myself
to draw on
also having this sort of set of
characteristics of defining moments
helps me at least know where to look and
then i just
i try to keep looking and until i found
what i need to find
it's interesting because we're talking
about defining moments for various
characters and knowing them sometimes if
i've watched a biopic i feel as if
the filmmaker has tried to cram in so
many defining moments that it loses some
of the impact of them and i think it's
because there's so much to tell yeah but
then i've seen documentaries where they
also do the same and for some reason it
lands better i i don't know why that
would be
i don't know i do think that um
the best biopics tend to focus on a
single event i i think of
spielberg's lincoln
and you know we know so much of abraham
lincoln's life and career
and
spielberg
tony kushner the screenwriter chose to
focus on
just a single vote
in the u.s house of representatives
about the amendment to the constitution
that outlawed slavery
and so out of everything you could look
at in lincoln's life and career
the film
focuses on a single event
and
i think we get
a bunch more
dramatic
power
focused when when we do that
and it can be really tempting
if you're doing a biopic because so many
interesting things happened in
um in many people's lives if we were
doing winston churchill there'd be so
many things
to focus on but the
fantastic film darkest hour
focuses
very specifically on
the
couple of weeks
leading up to winston churchill's speech
to parliament
where he declares we're going to fight
on the beaches we're going to fight on
the landing field where he galvanizes
the british people to oppose
the nazis
those
that that is a dramatic move
to
to restrict yourself in that way
and uh at the risk of sounding
disgustingly like a film professor i'll
go back to aristotle one more time
and
aristotle as long ago as that
said that the drama
should be about a single
event and i think that i think he's
right and i think that um
for reasons i don't understand
we are
we are geared toward a story of
a hero struggling against obstacles to
reach a goal there is a unity
to
drama
that
both focuses its power but also
helps to give it
meaning
because there's a
there's a configuration of events that
becomes meaningful
these choices and these actions led to
this outcome
so that's it gives us this sense of
completion that i think we
was one of the things that we long for
from our stories
when we're developing a character how
much are we charting out all of sort of
the
wonderful and terrible things that have
happened to them
are we doing this beforehand before we
get into the actual story we're kind of
coming up with a checklist
of defining moments
this
this is one of
the
confounding
qualities of storytelling
we don't have a linear process
uh where we do this first and the second
we sort of try we have to have we have
to approach
the story somehow
but i think that what we do is we
i typically have a notion for what is
the story what
maybe in a sentence
what is the story i want to tell
and that tells me something about a
character
and
and also something about the plot that
is it's somebody like this
trying to
you know climb out of a well and
so
um but then i go back to the character
and i said well i have more questions
for you character uh where did you come
from how did you get in that well
what were you doing in the field in the
first place
and
um
sometimes the answers are really
surprising to me
sometimes they come as sort of
epiphanies as i'm
out for a run or taking a shower or
lying in bed
often though they come as a result of
just
the ditch digging of sitting and asking
these questions
i know that this person
to be interesting
needs to have
both strength and weakness
when did they discover they had that
strength
when did they first experience
the the crippling quality of that
weakness
and um
then i come bring the character back to
the story
and now they're doing more interesting
things that i didn't expect them to do
because there's more
to that character and so i discover more
twists and turns
that are potential within
say the events or the plot of the story
and then i go back to the character so
i'm i think i'm
it's a very messy
uh recursive process
when i am finding these defining moments
for a character i don't know if any of
them will end up on screen
at first i'm just discovering what are
these moments
and then
so there are things i can do with a
defining moment i can just know about it
and it's going to inform how i write
dialogue for this character
other times i'm going to say
if i were writing
pixar's finding nemo i would say
oh that moment when marlin's whole
family gets eaten by a barracuda
i think we should see that
that's really visual and exciting and
tragic
would pixar allow us to start a
children's movie
with
that kind of scene
because if we were to do that
then we would really understand why
marlon is this overprotective father who
won't let
nemo
have any adventure have any fun
experience any danger and we won't view
him
just as
you know oh that neurotic marlin
we will feel with him well of course
he is a hyper-vigilant parent because
this tragedy struck him and we witnessed
it we experienced it with him
now when i first came up with that i
didn't somebody did if i was the one who
had come up with that i
i wouldn't have known at first does that
make it into the movie or not
there are other
moments that we don't see
but a character talks about
they just tell you the story of what
happened or they allude to the story
whatever makes great dialogue
and then other times there are moments
right in the middle of the movie
where a character transforms
and here i think the great example is
michael corleone and
the godfather
so we know that michael is a war hero
just back from world war ii
he's
the
son
who was not supposed to get mixed up
with the family's crime business he was
supposed to go on and maybe be a senator
maybe even a president
but after his father gets gunned down
michael decides he's got to take matters
into his own hands
and so he goes to meet
crime boss who had his father gunned
down
and the police captain who protects
that other crime boss because to meet
them at an italian restaurant he has a
gun planted in the bathroom
he
excuses himself from the table goes back
to the bathroom gets the gun
and then there's this long pause
as
michael
smoothes his hair
and
sort of allows himself to
make his choice
am i going to step across this threshold
from which there can be no return or not
and
then the director has set it up so
michael has to pass through three sets
of doors
as he returns into the restaurant from
the bathroom just to emphasize visually
this is a threshold
there is a
real boundary of before and after here
michael walks out into the restaurant
guns down the police captain and the
other crime boss
and
the rest of the movie
and the next movie and the next movie
the die is cast for all of those
in that moment of
the change of michael's legal status
from war hero to killer
there's also a moral and a spiritual
change that happens in him
and
he thinks he's done this for all the
best reasons for family
but in the end
he becomes someone who kills
members of his family
for the family
and he is
undone by this
action
by this choice that he's made in a
moment that defines him
so you find that moment and you think ah
that's probably a scene in the movie and
in fact that becomes the fulcrum of the
whole movie
the moment that
uh
defines michael
as
who will become the godfather
so you you find all of these
but they're like you know their cards in
your poker hand and you're not sure
where you're going to play them or even
if you're going to play them
and that is the messy organic
artistic process i suppose of
crafting a story but you can't craft it
if you don't have the raw materials
from which to craft it and i think that
defining moments are
one of
those really rich materials that
we have to work with when we're telling
stories about characters
if we look at forrest gump
does he have defining moments
wow that's a really interesting question
um
so forrest
yeah he experiences a moment
that
doesn't transform his inner nature his
inner nature is
is constant he is
he's an innocent
that's his genius
but when the movie opens he's an
innocent alone
and the moment that he climbs onto the
school bus and meets jenny
defines his life
his life will never be the same after
that moment that he climbs onto the
school bus and in fact there's dialogue
in the film where he says you know it's
i can't quote it but it's you know it's
funny what a a person remembers i don't
remember my first pair of shoes etc he
says
but i do remember
the first time i heard the sweetest
voice in the whole wide world
and he meets jenny on the bus she
invites him to sit beside her
and he says in very defining moment
language from that moment on
we was like peas and carrots
so
he experiences
a moment that defines him even though it
doesn't redefine his inner nature it
defines his experience of life
i think that
when forrest
finds out he's got a son
that is a transforming moment it
redirects the course of his life his
life will now be about
caring for a
little forest
and i think that jenny's death
is also probably a defining moment for
him because
his life at least as told in the movie
is bookended by meeting jenny
and then
losing jenny
but receiving from her the gift
of his son
and that then
will define
the rest of forrest's life
so
defining moments don't always transform
say the nature of a person
uh but they can still change the course
of of their lives i think we see that
with
jack in titanic
jack is not a character who really has a
big need to grow and change rose
definitely needs to be transformed when
we meet rose she's ready to leap off
the back of the ship to her death
by the time the movie's done
rose is all about surviving
so she has been transformed jack is
still kind of the same guy
but i think we could say that
meeting rose
is a defining moment for jack
and
if he had not met her
his
certainly those whatever three or four
days of the voyage would have been
different and while that sounds like a
short period of time that was
that was his whole life
that was all the life he had left
he might also say winning that card game
that got him the ticket on titanic would
also be a defining event in his life
yeah so with forrest gump it seems as if
there were maybe stronger in some sense
turning point like in terms of the
defining moments that changed a lot of
the people because if you look at
lieutenant dan you know he was so angry
he was so competitive he had so much
vengeance and then toward the end when
you see him at the wedding
he's he's a different person he's
transformed yes so for lieutenant dan
his life
was on a clear course
toward what he thought was his destiny
which was to die heroically in battle
which that was what his
family did
and
forrest intervened and
pulled him out of danger and
uh disrupted
the course that lieutenant dan thought
his life was supposed to be on so that
was a moment that redefined lieutenant
dan's life in a way lieutenant dan
despised
and
then lieutenant dan was on that course
of being completely unhappy with a life
that he saw as a he's been cheated
so all he's got now is just
emptiness
until
he is on
the shrimping boat in the middle of the
hurricane with forest
and he climbs up the mast in the middle
of that hurricane and has a screaming
match with god
over his destiny and forrest tells us
that
in that moment
he believes that god and lieutenant dan
somehow
came to peace with each other
and lieutenant dan is a different person
after that which makes possible
lieutenant dan showing up at the wedding
now he's got new legs he has a wife and
he's no longer
the bitter person
he's been made whole
and we
within the movie we have the two pivot
points
the
rescue which denied him his destiny
and then
the
confrontation
between lieutenant dan and god in the
midst of a hurricane which then makes
his growth possible so we can only
understand lieutenant dan's character
arc
through those two pivot points
and then with jenny
or she recommends for forrest you know
to run
to run from the bullies but really
that's a metaphor for what she'd been
doing all her life
and so we don't see her
toward the end until you know
she comes back and she's changed but we
just know that she was a runner yeah
herself and then she's she's much
different
yes and
in many ways
the moment that made it possible for her
to
come home
happened off screen
we we understand
well
we see her hit bottom when she when she
climbs up on that railing of a balcony
at a new year's eve party i think
and so we understand
that
uh either we've seen a defining moment
or that she is in the zone where those
things kind of happen
her return to forrest is evidence
that she has
had this transformative kind of
experience
but i think it shows us the defining
moments can be
uh kind of if we're talking about
playing cards they can be played in
different ways they can be played on
screen off screen
um through
just a character recounting something
that happened
or
um
we we end up with more defining moments
than we can actually use it's one of my
frustrations i was working today on my
next feature screenplay and the last two
pages after fade out are a nice little
dialogue scene that tells the story of
my main character's defining moment and
i know that that's going to fall out of
the script
because it just
it doesn't need to be in there
but i needed to know what that moment
was
so that i could write the rest of what
that character says and does
so even when these defining moments
don't end up on screen they still enrich
my understanding
this is also something that can be
really
valuable for actors
for them to understand not only
that this is true of my character
but why this is true of my character
so i'll
tell a story
out of school
when i worked at warner brothers in the
script department
the movie twister started shooting
before the script was fully written
and
[Music]
producer ian bryce called me up and said
can you send a script typist to oklahoma
to work with the writer as he finishes
writing this movie while we shoot it
and i said that sounds like too much fun
i'll send myself
so i was on a plane the next day to
oklahoma city and i ended up out in the
middle of a farm field with
300 vehicles and
making this big tornado action movie
helen hunt plays
a meteorologist who's chasing tornadoes
obsessively
for reasons that
no one knew at the moment because that
scene hadn't been written yet
so
she's having to go out and
try she's trying to put this psych
scientific instrument place it in the
path of a tornado so it'll be sucked up
and they'll learn all kinds of things
about tornadoes
she's putting her life at risk putting
her relationships at risk
and
at some point they know will write the
scene for her backstory the defining
moment that made her a tornado hunter
but they didn't need to film that
for several weeks into the future
and they didn't seem to take into
account that helen hunt as an actor
would like to know
why she's doing all these things
eventually they came up with what we
would
describe as a defining moment a moment
from her childhood when she experienced
a killer tornado
and that
birthed in her the dream that she would
someday make the world safer by getting
people more advance warning of tornadoes
my argument is it would have
been a real service
to helen hunt as an actor
to know what that was
while she was
chasing those tornadoes
and that i i'll just use as a metaphor
for the way that an understanding of
defining moments can be of use and a
value to
actors certainly
directors
editors
cinematographers
everyone
you know i described
the way
michael corleone is in the bathroom
in that
pivotal defining moment for the
godfather
you can see evidence
that everyone on the team appreciated
what that moment meant
for that character and for the film
the production designer had to design
three sets of doors
for
the character to walk through the
cinematographer had to arrange the shot
that way the editor
the composer
had to all support that moment not cut
past it because oh my gosh how much time
are we spending in this bathroom
nothing's going on in here
but everybody recognized that yes this
is where
michael is
going through this metamorphosis and so
we have to support
and
dramatize
all of the interaction that is happening
outside of our view somehow we have to
make that visible on the screen and the
entire team
understood intuitively or not
what a defining moment that was and
built an entire
film around that moment
we've talked a lot about
defining moments in
drama
but in comedy as well i mean we could
think of so many john hughes films that
had great defining moments
uh whether it was 16 candles or
home alone or something i mean
there's just
is there a difference in the way that a
comedic defining moment is done
you know i think
i i am not a comedy writer uh i it just
gives me terrible anxiety to think about
exchanging money for laughs
and i i have friends who
specialize in comedy i think it's a gift
that i don't have
but to the extent that i understand
comedy
comedy works a lot like drama
except it's just
funny you know we laugh so
when a character is pursuing a goal
they pursue it to absurd lengths
in a way that you wouldn't do in a drama
but
the character arcs
still often have to do with character
transformation
i think that the deepest and
like most satisfying
uh comedies really are dramas with
laughs and so
i i i think that these
defining moments absolutely exist
you might need a moment a defining
moment to help us understand
why a character would do the absurd
things that they do
uh
but
so that you know they may be a of a
different quality when i brainstorm my
20 possibilities i'm going to pick a
different defining moment in a comedy
than i am in a
gritty drama
just for tone
but it's still performing
those functions of
either explaining why the hero wants
what they want
why they need to grow and change the way
they need to
or that's showing us the transformation
as it unfolds step by step
you and kathy have a new book that just
came out the defense the defining moment
how writers and actors build characters
great and we're wondering if there are
certain chapters or a portion of the
book that you can reference first off a
moment or moments that damage or
a character do you have any references
we do because that's
that's something that
is
critically important uh in storytelling
because we're so often dealing with
characters who are damaged or crippled
so
kathy and i talk about
from the film finding nemo the way
nemo's dad marlin
is damaged by the tragic loss of his
family to a barracuda
but we also
try to
share some of our own defining moments
because we urge
storytellers
writers actors directors to
delve into their own histories
to find the moments that have defined
them in this case moments that have
damaged
wounded crippled them
in the history of our family
when we think of defining moments
there's one moment that
stands above all the others and it was
the moment when
uh our son peter as a five and a half
year old little boy
was diagnosed with a brain tumor
and
our pediatrician
put the mri films in our hands and said
you need to drive to ucla medical center
a brain surgeon will be waiting for you
and
he'll explain everything
so kathy and i got in the car and oh and
the doctor said and don't stop anywhere
on the way
so we put our son in the car
drove to the er and as we turned into
the entrance to the er
we looked at each other and
i think kathy was the one who said
in this moment
like our lives are changing forever
and that was true
we now in in our family talk about the
moment before peter got sick
and we talk about the moment after
peter's brain tumor
my daughter's life experience
was different from that moment on
her
best friend
um and brother
suddenly was
out of her life and in the hospital and
she wasn't seeing him and
when she did finally see him after
surgery he was changed
the tumor was gone
but he didn't speak
didn't
walk
he looked
to her
like a monster
and
for peter that was a defining moment it
was a moment that crippled him that made
him and peter
many years later is alive
but as a result of the surgery
radiation
which isn't good for little boy's brains
and chemotherapy
he's kind of a real life forest gump
pure of heart
and
he knows what love is
and he struggles
intellectually
so
that was a moment of
wounding for him
it was the beginning of the death
of the dreams
that we had for him
we had to
find new dreams to replace the ones that
died
and it took a long time though
we were the ones who were dragged
kicking and screaming
to
recognizing
the dreams that were not going to happen
now for him
even as we approached his 16th birthday
and
people his age were going to get
driver's licenses
none of us wants to live in a world
where peter reilly has a driver's
license because he just cannot process
all of the information fast enough and
he would get it right
95 of the time but that's not that's not
enough
on the streets of la
and so i had to
eventually say to him peter
you're not going to get a driver's
license
and so he's found a new dream he heard
about the google car
and so he's all about a self-driving car
as soon as he can get one he wants a car
that's going to take him wherever it can
take him
we had to absorb
a lot of of losses
but a day came when
peter had struggled along in school
got to high school
and
in california there's
a test you have to pass in order to get
a diploma
called the california high school exit
exam it's a standardized test
so no matter how much people at the
school loved him
and helped him
there was no way he was going to get a
diploma if he didn't pass this test
and i remember the day that the results
came in the mail and
i just heard kathy screaming in the
other part of the house she'd open the
envelope and he had passed by like
a whisker and
uh and so we got to go to his high
school graduation
and uh you know i've been in high school
and i know how it works people applaud
based on how popular you are when your
name is called and
so my family had all come to his
graduation and i was telling everybody
you've got to like
cheer your brains out because we have to
be as loud as possible
and kathy was just saying oh i just i
don't care about that i just hope he
doesn't fall off the stage
and
they called his name
and the entire senior class came to
their feet applauding because they all
recognized
what he had overcome
in order to
earn that diploma
kathy and i look at that experience as a
defining moment for us that was a moment
of healing it was a moment where we got
back
some of what we had lost
and
peter still struggles
he had another defining moment where
just in an afternoon he lost his hearing
and
that happened recently
further isolated him
and
made his life harder made our lives
harder it's really hard to
raise your voice so that he can hear us
and not feel angry when you're shouting
it's
your body won't disconnect shouting and
anger and so we're always struggling
with like how do i talk loudly enough
for him to hear me
and not have to apologize for it
afterwards
we are not unique
in experiencing moments of
loss one of the things that experiencing
loss has
sensitized us to
is that everyone
experiences
losses
and often those losses happen out of
view they're not
visible when we go to the grocery store
and
we believe it's true of our characters
as well
i think that
i think you can't work with characters
in this way without becoming more
compassionate
without becoming aware of what
people are suffering
and so in that way i i hope this book is
is a humanizing force within our
industry
and helps
people gain more compassion for one
another
and also for their characters
and maybe through their characters
even the audience will
will grow in the kind of compassion and
sensitivity and humanity
that
movies helped
to bring to me
our business could probably do with some
of that our world could probably do with
some of that
do you have a favorite chapter
you and kathy
definitely
i
you know i wrote
i wrote a book about script format a few
years ago and
this is a very different kind of book
because so much of our heart is on the
page
i think probably the the chapter
that guides the reader through
discovering their own defining moments
is my favorite chapter
it's the chapter where we share
um
many of our own moments
sometimes you know big moments like the
brain tumor moment but also
smaller quieter moments that have also
shaped us
we do that
as an encouragement
to
our readers
to be willing to look and find their own
defining moments and we also do it
as a way to model
what some of those moments look like and
how you might describe them
i think this book in some ways is
my response
to
seeing ordinary people
all those years ago
experiencing a film that reached out
and made connection with me as a human
being
and this book is me reaching back out
into the world
to
connect in the way that
i was connected with to help
readers feel
less alone
but this is a very
specific group of readers these are
these are our filmmakers these are our
actors and writers and directors and
novelists these are the people who tell
stories in our time
so i consider it a massive privilege to
get to have a voice
helping to equip storytellers to tell
stories that
that will help connect us
is there any
story you
the two of you struggled to
maybe leave in or leave out was there
one that you felt whether i mean you
shared some incredibly personal stuff
just here and i think it could be
beneficial for so many people but
there's a risk you know right and and
that's
yeah
yeah i think that uh kathy struggled
with how much to tell about
her relationship with her dad which was
not warm and close
um
he
he was a dad who never
ever said the words to her i love you
and she wants to honor her dad her dad
was a good man but he was not a warm man
and so she struggled with
whether to
put that story in her out of the book
and ultimately the stories in the book
uh she did it in a way that
was honoring to him
um she actually drew on
what she words she said at his funeral
and
for me
i think speaking of
this moment that i can't remember
a moment that
seems to be of abuse in my early early
childhood
is
uh
that was one that
i
hesitated to include
and wanted to be very
kind of
wise about how
how i told that story
but it's also
one of the stories i'm most
interested in
sharing because i think it could be
somehow encouraging or beneficial
to someone else
and
i i think i found my way to
understanding that story
through
films and documentaries that i
identified with and i was i was feeling
really powerful emotions watching
documentaries in ways that didn't make
sense to me that i should be reacting
that way
and
watching those films ended up leading me
into
a
counseling dialogue
that has like really helped me put my
finger on the lies
that had
had crippled me
uh and
allowed me then to figure out what was
actually true
so that's my hope is that in in sharing
these stories
um
stories become gifts that we give to
a reader to an audience
and stories work in a way that
is almost magical i can't explain how
stories work how each of us can hear the
same story read the same book watch the
same movie
and we connect with it in our in our own
way
we're moved by it in our own way we make
very personal application
so as we send these stories out into the
world i don't know
what
what will happen
but i'm hopeful and i look forward to
getting
some emails in return
can we talk about moments that heal or
repair a character
i love
moments in film
where there is
restoration of some kind that happens in
a way that seems
believable
that doesn't seem
shangri-la
i think about uh the film blood diamond
in this regard
so there's really two stories that
happen in blood diamond
um
we have the story of a south african
diamond
merchant
played by leonardo dicaprio
who is trafficking in these blood
diamonds i think this the movie takes
place in sierra leone
and so he's on the hunt for this giant
diamond that he's heard has been found
out in the mines that are run by
the rebel
military and the rebel military
conscripts
boys as child soldiers
both to fight for them but also to
work in these minds
the other main character is played by
jimin hansu
and he's the dad of a boy who has been
abducted
and taken away from his village
made to be a soldier who commits
atrocities
so this young boy
10 years old maybe
has
been made to do horrible things and his
dad
is determined to find his son
and somehow bring him back to the family
and as he's doing that he gets forced
into working
digging for diamonds
for the people who stole his son from
him and he finds this massive diamond
and he buries it
out away from the camp and
uh
continues looking for his son
leonardo dicaprio finds out
simon hansu's got this massive diamond
hidden
and at gunpoint takes him to dig up
this diamond
and
just as they're digging for this diamond
jimin hansu's son
shows up
and
is holding a gun on both men
leonardo dicaprio alerts jimin hansu
who's digging for the diamond
that his son is here
and so this father turns to his son who
now turns the gun to him
and
is
calling out the sons calling out for
help
and jimin hansu says
you're not one of them
you're my son and i'm your father
your mother waits for you your sister
waits for you
the wild dog who listens to no one waits
for you at home
you're not a bad boy i know they made
you do bad things
but you are going to come home to be me
and be my son again and i'm going to
love you
and
in the midst of this
the father is walking toward his son
walking toward the barrel of the gun
and
the son begins to cry
and slowly lowers the gun and allows
himself to be embraced by his father
that is written directed and acted in a
way
that
you believe that
that is a moment of
restoration and recovery that
maybe shouldn't even be possible
that it would be that you could recover
a child
who has been put through those
experiences
the film presents it with a kind of
emotional believability
that
certainly represents a defining moment
for
that boy and his father
that is going to be the pivot point
certainly this kid's going to need
probably
lots of therapy and lots of love over
lots of years
to
completely
emerge from
that awful darkness but in that moment
you believe
that there is real hope and
that
this
moment represents a before and after
that they will look back 10 years from
now
and see that is the moment
that the healing began that the
restoration began
and that love
began to eclipse hate in the life of
this boy
i think healing's like that
it doesn't
usually come in a moment
usually it comes
a little bit at a time but it has a
beginning
and as storytellers as filmmakers
we have the capacity to
aim the camera
aim the attention of the audience
at even the minutest movements
so that we are able to perceive
the moment
when
[Music]
a process of healing begins
and actually allow the audience to to
see feel and appreciate
what's happened
in a way that if we were on stage and we
were looking at the proscenium
like you'd miss it you'd never know what
was happening
we we have the capacity to
uh to zoom in
on
these massively significant movements of
character that are almost imperceptible
somebody has said that the job of the
artist is to see
and then to show others what they've
seen
and for me this is an example of that of
looking closely enough
to see this
monumental thing that's happening
in this tiny little frame
and blow that up so that
we see it we understand it we
we appreciate its meaning and we feel it
and it seems that combination of meaning
and emotion are
another of the things that we
we just really crave from our stories
just out of curiosity what was the
leonardo dicaprio character doing
during that moment
he was
he was standing and watching he had
he had his assault rifle
and
i think he was ready to shoot the boy
if
he felt he needed to
uh but he was he was also witness he was
bearing witness to this
miracle moment
so even i i haven't seen the film but
because his intentions sounds like they
were not that honorable either okay so
he but he's seeing this and do you see a
little bit of change in that character
at all yes yeah after that
he he discovers that actually he's been
shot in the fire fight that happened
just before this scene
he ends up
really sacrificing himself
to help father and son escape
so yeah it does actually
um transform him
to have witnessed this moment
before you and kathy wrote the defining
moment what was your process for writing
characters
kathy and i approach
character from lots of different angles
because
characters are
slippery
critters that you know have a lot of
facets a lot of dimensions
for many years we have
asked these questions about what are the
moments that define these characters
so that's a really important part of
what we've always done
we also
we have a set of what we call the hero
questions
where we ask things like what does this
character want
because every character is driven by
by some intention
uh and then we ask how does this
character need to grow and change
because the most interesting characters
uh very often do
transform in some way or even adjust not
all characters and all genres transform
but uh often there's at least a small
growth or adjustment in them and that's
that's satisfying that's where some of
the emotion comes from for the audience
we ask what terrible thing will happen
if the hero doesn't get what they want
and that helps us zero in on the stakes
of the story
uh for the the external stakes and we
ask what terrible thing will happen if
they don't grow and change
in the way they need to
and that gets at the internal stakes
and we ask
how's the audience going to relate to
this character what are they going to be
rooting for
in relation to this
character because we're really convinced
that
if we are not
rooting for our protagonist
we're not going to be invested
emotionally in the outcome of the story
and so if we don't care
we're bored
we also
um
we've got a list of character
qualities that i've stolen from my
friend
uh dr sydney showers
and so i call those dr showers eight
character traits
and she is a list she's a
gifted writer
who's just compiled this list of
character traits
and they include some of the things that
are
included in the hero questions but she
asks some other things she asks about a
character's drive
and by that she means what is that motor
even outside of
the specific problem that's being solved
in this movie there's a killer asteroid
headed toward earth and so our goal is
to
save the earth well what
what drives that character the rest of
the time
are they a person who's all about
protecting people
throughout their lives everywhere or is
it
about
they're driven by recognition
and so i want to
save the earth because it'll make me
famous
and so that's that's the idea of the
character's drive
she thinks about the character's genius
and her ideas that every character has
some strength or genius whether it's
high iq or in the case of forrest gump
it's not high iq but it's purity of love
purity of heart
could be your great cello player
it's um it's something
that is a strength a character has
and then she thinks about
uh
characters
flaw
and also
their weakness as two different things
the weakness she thinks of as
uh just an inability to do something i
don't write comedy that's my weakness
i'm sure
one element in a very long list the flaw
she thinks of more as a moral failure
a person's proud cruel selfish
fearful something
[Music]
all of
all of these are just questions
that prompt
me prompt kathy to think about our
characters
and then we also get some insight into
our characters by letting them talk
so
when i was writing
with kathy our german film after the
truth
that's a movie that's about
the auschwitz doctor joseph mengele
and
i knew that i needed to
capture his voice as part of his
character what kinds of things does
mengelis say
and so i sat down one afternoon and i
just kind of wrote a rant
in his voice i just sort of allowed
myself to
inhabit that character i read everything
i could find out about him every word
that we knew he had written
and
and i inhabited that character and just
wrote in his voice and i wrote a lot it
wasn't dialogue it was more of a
kind of a blog post from joseph mengele
and and then i
whatever the opposite of inhabited
disinhabited that character and i never
went back in there
but i was able to just go back
to
those pages
of
journal entry or blog post in that
character's voice as kind of a tuning
fork
that allowed me to write in that
character's voice
and i've done that for other characters
as well as a way of
pinning down
a character's voice
and being able to then draw on that
it's almost
i don't know anything about making
sourdough bread but i think that you've
got this starter and you just you keep
you just need a little bit of it to get
the dough going and that's how that
works
you've got that starter and that allows
you then to
write
dialogue for any scene from that
character
it's it's a messy iterative process
often i will think about a character as
i'm going to sleep at night
and
i'll wake up and have some new insight
into them
i i really think that it's just it's
we need different strategies to just get
us coming back over and over and over
again to our characters and giving us
ourselves the opportunities to make more
discoveries about them
and just to go back to this metaphor
about the the sourdough starter if i
understand it correctly that you can
keep some of the starter still there
in a cupboard covered up so it sounds
like two
maybe there's with this checklist that's
like the starter that you're keeping
because you're you're gonna go back to
this checklist that you talked about in
the book that you have
what is it like 20
questions or so yeah so the
i don't even know how many hero
questions plus
if we add
dr showers eight character traits that
probably does get us to about 20.
um yeah right
writing a movie especially
or writing a tv series
it's a massive project and
having a starter
is uh is a big help uh just a place to
grab that first thread and and start
pulling so it's
it's not a formula it's not paint by
numbers
but it at least is a way to say here's
how i'm going to start my work today
and
make contact
with this character
i've
for the first time in my life i directed
a short film
recently
and
so i had to write the script i did all
of my write it writerly character stuff
but then there were weeks of prep and
pre-production casting working with
actors and then shooting
which allowed me to just keep coming
back to these characters over and over
and over again what i discovered is
you keep learning new things every time
you sit down with your characters
you learn more and more and more and
eventually it's more than you can fit in
the movie
so things start overflowing and falling
out
but far better to come at this work
with
this overflowing
just richness
of
character and knowledge about these
characters that you can't even fit it
all into the movie
i think that's what the audience wants
is a real density of ideas
we just keep discovering more
and the only way the audience is going
to keep discovering more is if we have
before them
discovered more and more and more how
has the defining moment changed the way
you write characters
i think that
i began my writing life as a pretty
lazy guy with
low ambitions i wanted to be just good
enough to get to play in the game
which is ridiculous because nobody who's
aiming to be mediocre gets to play in
the game
kathy is much more about let's
not do the least we can let's do the
most we can
so from the
the moment that we learned about
defining moments
kathy has been all about let's do our
homework let's really dig into these
characters
and
i've
i've had to grow into the discipline of
it
and as i've
as i've been willing to invest the
effort
into
spending time to really deeply
understand my characters rather than
rushing ahead because i can't wait to
write that scene where
the thing blows up
my writing gets better and deeper
[Music]
so
i'm excited now every time i approach a
new character
because
i am
i'm just asking
i'm asking all these questions and
requiring myself not to rush ahead but
to take the time to really enrich
the characters enrich the script the
script i'm writing right now i'm
actually in a rewrite process
where i'm
i i paused
and did all this defining moment work
because i felt like a hypocrite you know
having written the book i need to
actually do this
made wonderful discoveries
and i'm now in the process
of
of enriching the script with all of
those insights
so for me it's
it's made my writing i think objectively
better richer more emotional
and the character is just more
interesting
so when you you first started as a
writer what were some of the characters
what were some of the the films that you
wanted to emulate aside from
you know we talked about ordinary people
yeah so besides ordinary people um the
deer hunter was also a film that was uh
very influential on me
and then
this is completely
from a different genre
raiders of the lost ark that's just for
me so much fun
uh steven spielberg really understands
how to tell a story with action it's not
random action
and
we are really with the character in the
midst of it we understand
what's going on what has to be achieved
what all the threats are
and then he tumbles you in that film out
of the frying pan into the fire time
after time you end one action sequence
and you tumble
into the beginning of the next one
so that one for me is just a lot of fun
and
teaches me the movie
movie going
can be fun it doesn't have to just be
you know this emotional
um ripping open of the soul
the elephant man
is a film that i really love
and
um
a real character
study a study of
the connection between
two characters who are very different
and in that movie
it's the audience that's transformed
so the first time that the elephant man
is seen on screen
we
like cover our faces and turn away and
horror at his hideousness
he doesn't change but by the end of that
movie we are like on a close shot
of his face
and all we can see is his beauty
he didn't change but we changed
and i love that
film that story
can do that that it can change what we
see
chris we had this comment come in
overnight and so beautifully written i
wanted to read it it's from user half
xbreed23
and they write i think a lot of writers
have an obsession with their characters
which keeps the story from growing
because they're too in love with them
nothing is greater than the story nobody
is greater than the story story is the
sun characters are flowers
the story allows characters to bloom
i love that i love that awesome yeah i i
think that's right uh characters
are in service to story
and by story we don't mean plot
the story is the
totality of the characters
doing what they do as they struggle with
all of the challenges they face
and
a beautiful line
that doesn't support the story has got
to be cut
i
i think one of the great challenges is
after i've said we should you know dig
into our own defining moments when we
base a character on ourselves
and it becomes too autobiographical
that can limit us
because one of the things we have to
look at are the characters flaws and
complexities and i don't want to
think about my complexities my
contradictions
where am i a hypocrite
put that on the page for the world
so if
um
if i'm not willing to let the character
and the story go where they need to
i can end up kind of wrapping duct tape
around that character
uh and preventing them from
pursuing
their own life
and this sounds
absurd unless you're a writer characters
will surprise us characters say things
we did not know they were going to say
that's such an electric exciting moment
when that happens
i can't quite explain how that happens
and
yes if we treat our characters like um
you know the
whatever
antique barbie and ken dolls that we
don't want to take out of their boxes
because they're too valuable in their
perfection
we will
hamper
the story that that could unfold if we
let them cut loose a little bit
it's a great analogy yeah
so being too precious like you have your
collection up there
and you can show it
um but you can't really do anything with
it right yeah you got to get the dolls
out of the boxes and play with them um
and that's the point of all of this
character development is to get to the
place where we can now
get them out and play with them and put
the astronaut doll in the gemini capsule
and blast it off and see what happens
and you know let barbie and ken fight it
out and see what happens that's
that's the play that happens when we get
past all this character development and
we actually start writing pages
that's that's where the fun is that's
where the life
comes so
character development is not an end in
itself the story
is the end
chris i heard you say and maybe a
michael we see video that a story is a
hero's struggle against an obstacle to
reach a goal
yes so i
first came across that quote from
television writer bill eidelson
reading an article in the writer's guild
magazine
and
i just have found that to be the e
equals m c squared
of the physics of storytelling
it gives us three elements gives us our
hero
gives us
a goal
and then the obstacles against which the
heroes struggles
that's not everything that happens in
story but
it allows us to understand at
an elemental level
what is happening in the story
so
in
steven spielberg's lincoln
it's the story of abraham lincoln
struggling against
all of the forces
of
the u.s house of representatives who
don't want to outlaw slavery
to
pass an amendment to the united states
constitution outlawing slavery
now i didn't try
i just gave you the hero gold obstacle
but i gave you a log line for the movie
and the log line was just the hero goal
obstacle dynamic
put into a sentence
it brings the story into focus
it'll it identifies the single action
that aristotle said
that a drama needs to be about
and it puts the focus on the character's
struggle
so if a story is the hero's struggle
against an obstacle to reach a goal then
the story juice is in the struggle
and
we so we want to spend most of our
page count
dramatizing that struggle
that gives us
force and focus
uh for a story it helps us know what the
story is
so we can judge what serves the story
and what doesn't what's a distraction
i
i just find it to be
such a clarifying lens
a story is not only that there's also
claudia hunter johnson wrote a great
book called crafting short screenplays
that connect
and she talks about the power of
connection and disconnection between
characters and how much emotion comes
from connection you can think about a
touch a kiss as a connection or
two characters whose eyes meet and they
realize against all odds they're
actually on the same side
or a disconnection of betrayal and just
to say betrayal we we feel the emotion
that goes with that
and then there are missed connections
near misses longed for connections that
never happen
all of that swirls around
heroes
struggling toward goals against
obstacles
so i find that to be um
so so useful when i'm figuring out the
structure of
a whole movie
or the structure of an individual scene
we can think about even the sprawling
three movies or three books of lord of
the rings
it's all about frodo
carrying a ring to mount doom to destroy
it
struggling against all the forces of
mordor
it's a single action across all three
three hour long movies
and
the filmmakers never lose sight of what
the story is the story is
frodo struggling against the forces of
mordor to destroy the ring
lots of stuff happens in that movie
and we also we actually kind of feel
the energy drain
when we step away from that central
thread when we're
with mary and pippen in the trees
uh we sort of feel
the temperature turned down on the
urgency
and the focus of that
tom bombadil which for readers of the
book
um they know
there's maybe a hundred pages about some
guy named tom bombadil has nothing to do
with frodo trying to get rid of that
ring
and so rightly that just falls out
of the movies
because it doesn't serve
the imperative of movies which is all
about what happens next
and hero goal obstacle helps us to know
what we mean when we say well what
happens next is what happens next as the
hero's struggling toward the goal
and forgive me you talked about this
other movie and that is that blood
diamond yes okay and i have not seen it
but um if i'm keeping with what i
believe you said was sort of this
premise it seems like they're all their
common goal is this diamond or these
diamond mines and having access to them
well so
each in this case we've got
two protagonists we've got leonardo
dicaprio whose goal is
make all the money he can from these
diamonds
and then jimin hansu whose goal is
rescue my son
and so here we've got two stories that
intersect
and
so we could call that uh i think robert
mckee calls that a multi-protagonist
story
which is
which is to say you've got
multiple protagonists each with their
own goal
and they succeed or fail
individually
you can also have buddy movies or movies
with
several people on a team
all struggling toward the same goal and
they succeed or fail together and mckee
calls those plural protagonist movies
plural protagonist movies are more of
the classic
structure that we see in say hollywood
movies
multi-protagonist movies are more art
house things they're much harder to do
but you know those movies like crash and
traffic and magnolia that's where you
see
uh and babel
multi-protagonist movies
and i think that's what's going on with
blood diamond
right and so
the real goal though isn't this this
diamond the real goal is is the
realization that this father loves the
son and he's trying to save him from
yeah so it's an interesting thing you've
got um
sort of your stated goal
i i'm going to rescue my son i'm going
to get that diamond
some characters have the wrong
goal or
their need for growth is far more
important
than their stated goal
leonardo dicaprio's
goal
he's got the wrong goal he just wants to
be rich he wants diamonds
that's the wrong goal
what he really needs to do is find
something that is worth more than
diamonds and that's people that's love
and he does
so
the audience recognizes that and they
say oh you didn't get your goal
but you grew in the way you needed to so
i can still feel good about that but
if you die along the way it's
bittersweet
and so that's cool you know it's it's
not the the neat bow
um whereas
jimin hansu the dad who's looking to
rescue his son it's not really a story
about his
inner growth
for him we are invested in him actually
achieving his goal of rescuing his son
which will require his son's
transformation
so that's where we get the
and the emotion that accompanies that in
that story
and those two end up being intertwined
uh at the end but they uh
they unfold independently for the first
uh
good part of that movie
you said that mostly art house cinema
does sort of like these multi
protagonist films well
if you've got a multi-protagonist film
it is going to be probably less of a
blockbuster
and so
yes you may end up having an art house
film if you do that
um
mostly studio films are going to be
the
more classic single story that we're
telling whether with one protagonist or
many working together so
like a multi or a plural protagonist
story a lot of
protagonists working together would be
the oceans 11 12 13 movies you've got a
team of people who are all trying to
pull off the same heist
and they succeed or fail together
do villains have defining moments
i think that they certainly can uh
sometimes we get villains who are
very cardboard cutout
just
you know gleefully
wreaking havoc
for for the heck of it but
i think of a
of a classic
film spider-man 2
and
there doc ock has a defining moment he
isn't evil for the sake of evil
he is a man who is wounded through the
death of his wife
that's the moment that defines him
and
in
spider-man 2
written by the same writer who wrote
ordinary people
we get a villain who actually
has an arc
and who transforms and in the end
is able to
take a step back
from
[Music]
the evil and
to actually sacrifice himself
uh
to join with spider-man
and
to save the city
so
yes i and i think that spider-man 2
plays a really important role in the
history of
superhero action films
we look back and
uh we may not recognize that because
we're used to superhero action films
that have rich character development
but spider-man 2 really
took that up a huge step
by
in part
looking deeply in to the character of
their villain and by providing
the
uh the depth and complexity and
dimension
that
defining moments
afforded that character
and when we do see these defining
moments for these villains
is it to have the audience turn
to to have some empathy toward
that antagonist or is it just to further
understand sort of the arc of the story
i think the effect is that we actually
do have some empathy
uh for that villain
and and it's not to say that we like the
villain or we agree with the evil the
villain does
but it's to say that we recognize the
villain's humanity
and we say oh
you are
at least a little bit like me we are the
same species
and there are a lot of different ways to
approach villains we can approach
villains as other just completely
different from me and outside of me
but
you think about
pinocchio so if we go way back to
a very disturbing children's animated
film
a scene where pinocchio is at the pool
hall
and
he and the other boys are
drinking and smoking cigars and playing
pool and being transformed into donkeys
that's a vision of evil
that
says oh
there is no difference
between us and them
we are them
and that
is
a cautionary tale but it also does lead
to a kind of empathy where we can
recognize
oh that villain is really broken
and what they're doing
may be
horrible and actually we may call it
evil
but they are also one of us
and
uh for my storytelling money that's uh
that's closer to what i
resonate with as like yeah i think
that's how it is
how are the decisions of the villain
different from the hero
in many ways the hero and villains
decisions are the same they're driven by
the way they see the world and what they
want when i
am writing
[Music]
an antagonist and i will often think in
terms of antagonist as opposed to
villain
because villain
[Music]
is more condemning than i think i'm i'm
ready to be with most of my characters
joseph mengeles certainly was a villain
and
did
pure evil
and he was a human
which is what
made him so interesting to me as a
character
what allowed us to write joseph mengele
in a way that
i think was so disturbing
and
ended up getting the actor
best actor nomination for the european
film award
was
that um we approached him as a character
who thought he was the hero
and i think that
everyone sees themselves as the hero of
their story
they do what they do for the reasons
they do them
and even when they do something that
they would recognize is like okay that
was bad
but you have to understand i had a
really good
justification why i had to do that
it's part of the genius of michael
corleone's character
we understand with every choice he makes
why he makes it and we cringe because
sometimes he's killing family members
but we always recognize
the reasons that he does it
and it creates this cognitive dissonance
for us because we're saying oh no that's
like don't you shouldn't do that and at
the same time i totally understand why
you just did that
i think that gives us really fascinating
antagonists and villains
if
we do
we do the same character development for
them
that we do for any other character
i don't think that means we have to have
really fuzzy moral judgment i think we
can still
recognize evil as evil
and recognize the humanity of the people
who are doing the evil at the same time
it's um
it's a more nuanced approach i think
it's
more interesting and i think again i
think it
it rings true to me for how
people actually are i haven't like i
don't think i've ever met
a villain
at vaughn's you know i i i've
i've met people doing dumb things and
being irresponsible and uncaring
um
but
they think they're right
and
um
so
i i try to approach all my characters
with love
even the ones that are
wicked
how do writers get audiences to care
about the villains
i think that
on the one hand
you could get away with the audience not
caring about the villains even
gleefully rooting
for the destruction of the villain
but
the example of spider-man 2 shows us
that there is
emotional
gold to be mined in providing
a glimpse into the humanity
of
a villain
so the in the same way
that we would
reveal a character
say a heroic character to the audience
so that they can understand where that
character's coming from
we can use those same tools
to reveal
who this villain is and why this villain
is how
what journey this character has been on
to arrive at their villainy
the
i think the emotional experience then
becomes really complex
because now
[Music]
i am
i recognize that character
has to be stopped
uh i'm thinking of the camp commandant
in schindler's list
where we really do get
some insights into this character into
his vulnerability into
there's
there's a moment where
he toys with showing mercy
to people
and
then he
pulls back from that it's like that's
not me i'm not i'm not going to be that
guy who is merciful
but the fact that he had that moment
where he could have been merciful
colors the way we feel about him when
he's executed at the end of the film
it makes it more complicated in a way
that i think enriches
the experience
never confuses us
about the evil that he's perpetrated
the film never has any confusion about
that the evil is evil
but it does show us the complexity of
the person perpetrating the evil which
does i think
make for a more interesting
storytelling experience
do you have any practical exercises that
writers can do for defining or
redefining their characters
i do actually so in in the book
we approach practical exercises in
uh
a variety of different ways
so the first set of practical exercises
has to do
with
walking
writers through
a discovery of their own defining
moments
and that can be
that can be a pretty
emotional
thing to do to go back and and really
touch
those moments that have shaped us
in wonderful ways and terrible ways
and then we also
provide a set of exercises
that walk a writer through
discovering
their character's defining moments
and
those are
very kind of practical
here's the thing to do now set this much
time
on
you know on the timer
and
start writing and keep writing until the
timer goes off
i i'm a
kind of a believer in what
um
anne lamott talks about
small assignments
and in her book bird by bird
writing can be really daunting
uh because it's it's like
running a marathon
it's just
so much you can't imagine how much it is
and so
starting can be really really hard
every day when i start writing it's
still
that's the hardest thing i do
requires the most discipline and once
i've tipped over into writing
then i'm going
but it's like taking that first plunge
into the cold swimming pool in the
morning you just kind of have to give
yourself a push in the back and these
exercises are designed to say all right
blank sheet of paper pick up a pen
here's your prompt
now go
i find that when writers do that
they end up writing things they didn't
mean to write
they uncover things they didn't know
were there
and
i really love it when
[Music]
we just start writing and
require ourselves to keep the pen moving
now this is a very physical way to
approach it
apart from a keyboard i think somehow
there's
some value in
actually writing with a
pen or pencil and paper
and so a prompt might be
you know think of your character
think of
how they need to grow and change
now
why have they not grown and changed in
that way yet
or
think of the way
your characters say your character's
strength or their genius
when was the first time
they realized that they had that
strength or genius
write about that for five minutes
and so you might start by writing
i'm not even sure like he knows
how good he is at the trombone
and
um
i'm not sure why he doesn't know or why
he's playing the trombone in the first
place and then you eventually if you
just keep writing
you stumble upon something that you
didn't know you were going to stumble
upon
and
what is it about the trombone
that is just perfect for his personality
what's happening when he's playing the
trombone what is he feeling and
that's a
really terrible example but it um
it
it shows how just doing exercises
allows you to start finding these little
starters
that will lead to bigger things
one of the chapters i think we start
with the sentence characters start at
zero
meaning
as the storyteller i don't know anything
about the character when they first pop
into my mind
nor does the audience know anything
about a character
just before they step on stage
and i will only know what i know about a
character
through what i discover about them
and the audience will only know about a
character through what i reveal about
them
so i have to somehow get myself
to engage with this discovery process
and once i've
mounded up all of this raw material
then i'm ready to start writing and
doling that out
in a strategic way
as i tell the story these exercises are
designed to give
writers and actors and directors
practice
thinking about and working with
characters in this way so that all of us
can make
the discoveries
that are going to make for rich and
lifelike characters who can transform
before our eyes
you know when you mentioned anne
lamott's bird by bird i believe the
title
if i remember correctly is based on a
conversation she had with a grandfather
or uncle
where you just take it a little bit of a
time bird by bird yes i think she had to
write a report about
birds and she was looking out the window
maybe at a flock of birds and she was
just overwhelmed how am i going to do
this
i think her dad was a professional
writer or professor and he said well ann
just take it bird by bird
and i think that's just some of the best
advice for any writer
how can an actor use defining moments to
build their character
kathy and i interviewed
several actors
as we were writing this book because we
really wanted to understand how
how these ideas could be useful to
actors
we talked to
two-time emmy winner tony hale
and talked to him about this and he said
you know
um
i have found that when i will dig into
my own
moments that have shaped me and defined
me
the performance changes in a way that is
appreciable he had just come from
recording
a voice
for an animated project
and he said
and i did that i tapped into something
that was really real and deep for me
and you could just tell the energy in
the booth changed when i did that
and he said i don't know why i don't do
that all the time
i suppose
it's costly emotionally to do that
but
he absolutely recognized that
by
thinking about
the single character that he's embodying
and portraying
seeking to understand what are the
moments that really have shaped and
define this character
how do those moments connect with my own
life experience
he's able to infuse
greater depth and complexity
into
those characters
he said when he auditions
he
seeks to bring
himself in that way
to the role
and he says i you know i may not
when i audition for that role may not be
the tallest or the this or that that
they're looking for
but i can guarantee
that i will have delivered an audition
that nobody else delivered
because they can't they don't have
access
to his inner life only he does
that is the unique
gold that he can mine and bring forward
in auditions and performances and
i think any actor uh can benefit from
that
and
what i think is so useful for me as a
writer and for actors is that
we're talking about a limited number of
things that we need to discover about
the character
we don't have to know everything about
every year of their lives we just need
to locate those moments that have most
shaped them
and it gives us this deep understanding
that
gives all of us access in an empathetic
way to the humanity of that character
but possibly the actor could have
a history in their back pocket and it
might lend to
a heaviness here a relief here
yeah exactly and and that's that's for
me as a as a writer a really exciting
thing i'm collaborating with an actor to
create this character i do my part first
and then i pass the baton to the actor
and the director
and
they bring their resources which are
different from my resources
and when it all works
the way we dream it will work
then you get this
really rich character who does things
that the writer never even imagined
and the actor has got to hope that the
writer
put
on the page
enough
for them to work with and then they can
pick up that baton and carry it further